the enna golodryga is a Yahoo News and
Finance anchor she was born in Moldova
in the former Soviet Union and has
covered the US and Russia story
extensively beyond a good morning to you
Russia is not gonna help the u.s. in
this situation are they yeah I can't
imagine that Russia will be helping the
US nor is that on their agenda you heard
the president saying he doesn't have
much of an agenda going into this well I
think North Korea changed he says no
formal agenda bit seems like this will
now give them something else to talk
about yeah I think it will give them
something to talk about it in a sense
this is a plus for a president Trump and
in a way that he doesn't necessarily
have to focus on sanctions doesn't have
to focus on the cyberattacks it's not to
focus on Ukraine or even Syria first and
foremost are going to be focused on
North Korea North Korea is bordered with
Russia right now so Russia does have a
vested interest in de-escalating the
tension Russia unlike China however
doesn't have much leverage given that
there's not much of a trading
relationship between the two countries
having said that Russia does employ some
North Koreans as well so there is
something for them to bring to the table
and we've heard from Putin at right now
with China saying that listen we think
that North Korea can freeze their
nuclear ambitions if the u.s. and South
Korea sort of curtail their military
exercises in the region what do you
think that Putin wants from this meeting
well if this will be their first meeting
between Vladimir Putin and Donald Trump
the pressure is very high
Putin unlike President Chirac who do you
think pressure on well obviously
pressure on President Trump because he
sort of boxed in in in many ways here if
he doesn't bring up the cyberattacks if
he doesn't bring up Ukrainian sanctions
then you're gonna hear a lot of backlash
here at home there's a lot of
anticipation but for Vladimir Putin
remember one of his biggest angst was
being called a regional power by
President Obama he wants to look like a
global power and in a sense everything
that we've talked about this past year
leading up to the election has put him
in those ranks this will be their first
meeting before President Putin is
expected to launch a reelection campaign
next year he does want to look like he's
coming away with something and from what
we're hearing at home the president has
asked for deliverables to give to
Vladimir Putin so Vladimir Putin is
really going to look as if he he
coming away with something at least
that's what he wants to appear to be
like the president also said back in
April that it's an all-time low the
relationship between Russia and the US
so what do you think is going to really
come from this looks the bar is not very
high in the sense that if the president
doesn't give away classified information
to the Russians that's going to be seen
as an achievement if he doesn't have
these photo ops where he looks like he's
very cordial and comfortable with
Vladimir Putin that will be an
achievement as well so you want the
president coming in with a sense of
talking points obviously North Korea has
given him that but I will be curious and
I do think it is important to bring up
Ukraine to bring up sanctions and he can
do it in a way that says listen I want
to release these and lift these
sanctions as much as you do but in
Russian election meddling we keep
hearing there's no formal agenda that
you know if you will just see how it
goes should he bring that up absolutely
he should bring that up and he doesn't
have to bring it up in the sense of
listen I think that's the reason why I
won you know there's all this pressure
and in that you sort of hack the
election you don't have to go there all
that you have to say is listen let's
work on a play and a plan to to
eliminate cyberattacks going forward in
future elections we hear that they're
meddling in European elections there's a
German election coming up obviously we
have elections here at home in 2018 and
2020 if there's any way that we can
deescalate cyberattacks coming from both
sides then that's something that they
can start with because you know that
unglue Merkel is going to be raising
this issue with him if the President
Trump does not there will be a lot to
watch on Friday good to see you it's a
guy exactly for I want to sing your name
[Laughter]
thank you very much